SUE RUNSTROM: My
name is Sue Runstrom.
I'm hosting Dorie Clark, and
very happy to be doing that.
Dorie Clark is an adjunct
professor at the Business
Administration at Duke
University's Fuqua
School of Business and
author of "Reinventing You,"
and her new book, right
back there, "Stand Out."
A former presidential
campaign spokeswoman,
she is frequently contributing
to "Harvard Business Review,"
"Time," and "Entrepreneur."
Recognized as a branding
expert by Associated Press,
"Inc.," and "Fortune," Clark is
a marketing strategy consultant
and speaker for
clients including--
guessed it-- Google, Microsoft,
Yale, Fidelity, and The World
Bank.
You can learn more at her
website at dorieclark.com.
Welcome, Dorie Clark.
DORIE CLARK: Thank you, Sue.
And hello, Google.
We live in a world today that
is getting faster by the minute.
The average employee gets
more than 100 emails per day.
And that rate is
growing by 15% a year.
Very soon, it's going
to be unsustainable, .
If it's not already you
guys here at Google probably
are already in the
forefront of that.
We live in a world where,
in the past minute that Sue
has been introducing
me, 100 hours of video
was uploaded to your very
own product, YouTube.
With all of that,
people and information
is streaming at you.
20 years ago, it may
have made good sense
to follow your mom
or dad's advice
to just keep your head
down and do good work,
and that that would eventually
be noticed and rewarded.
But these days, with
people being so bombarded
with information, with Tweets
and meetings and emails
and text messages and SnapChats
and Instagrams coming at them,
it's too much for
people to take in.
If we don't find a way to
take control of our careers
and to stand out, we
risk being left behind.
That's why I wrote
the book, "Stand Out,"
because I wanted to
try to understand.
Among the people who are
considered the very best
in their field, how
did they get there?
How did they come
up with the ideas
that they became known for,
and how did they actually
get recognized and build
a following around them?
So I spent a couple
of years interviewing
about 50 top experts
in a cross-section
of different fields, everything
from genomics, to real estate,
to urban planning, to
business, to productivity,
to try to understand what
enables the top performers
today to really get noticed and
have their true talents seen,
so that hopefully,
we could apply
some of those same lessons to
regular professionals today.
One of the first things
that I wanted to talk about,
because I've been traveling
around the country
in the past couple of months
since "Stand Out" came out,
is the fact that sometimes,
when I'm having conversations
with people about this,
they say, oh, you know,
this is great.
Yeah, I get it that
we need to stand out,
that it's important to
have breakthrough ideas.
But that's something that's
good for other people.
That's not me.
I'm just a regular person.
I'm not a genius.
I don't know that I
can really do this.
And one of my very
favorite examples,
actually, is
Starbucks, something
that even just walking here
from the T, you see a million
of them on every corner.
Howard Schultz
didn't invent coffee.
He didn't invent coffee shops.
What he came up with was
a slightly different way
to do a coffee shop.
And yet that was enough to
create a multi-billion dollar
worldwide empire.
You don't need to be Einstein.
You don't need to create
the theory of relativity
or to discover a new element
on the periodic table.
What you need to do is find
a slightly different way
to look at the world.
And fortunately, because
of your unique experiences,
because no one sees the world
exactly the way that you do,
that's something that actually
is eminently possible.
One of the people that I profile
in "Stand Out" is this woman.
Her name is Rose Schumann.
Rose grew up in
suburban Maryland,
and when she was 18 years
old, she took a family trip
to Nicaragua because that's
where her stepmother was from.
It was shortly after the
end of the Contra War,
and Rose went down
with her family.
And she had never
seen anything like it.
She grew up in a comfortable
suburban environment,
and she was exposed,
for the first time,
to a country where all of
the institutions that we take
for granted weren't operating.
There was one
operative streetlight
in the entire country.
There was poverty
unlike anything she
had ever seen before.
And she decided that she wanted
to do something about it.
And so she did.
She went off to college.
She studied development.
She got a job after she
graduated in an NGO,
and she started
working on the problems
and rolling up her sleeves.
Now one of the most common
myths about innovation,
about creativity, about coming
up with breakthrough ideas,
is that the people who have them
have these bolts of insight.
Suddenly the muses are
whispering in their ear,
and they know what they have to
do, and then they go and do it.
And sure, I'm sure in some
cases it works like that.
But for the vast majority
of people-- and I
think this is really important--
the vast majority of people,
you don't start with a brilliant
idea and then execute it.
When I interviewed
these 50 top thought
leaders to try to
understand what
made them tick, what I
heard again and again
was actually the
opposite of that.
You start by caring
about something.
You start with curiosity.
You start by having a
passion to explore something,
and in the process of diving
into it, learning about it,
seeing what it's made of and how
you can make a contribution--
that is how you can determine
where you can have an impact,
and what kind of
change you can make.
In Rose's case, she
had been working
on these issues
for several years
before lightning struck her.
One day she was walking around,
and she saw one of these.
She saw a call box like you'd
see at a transit station.
Pretty simple.
Push a button, talk to somebody
on the other end of the line,
ask a question, or
make a complaint,
get your problem solved.
And Rose saw this,
and she realized
that this problem that had
been in the back of her mind
for so long-- how do you get
the power of the Internet
and bring it to the
world's poorest one
billion people-- that might
actually be how to do it.
There's a lot of
strategies that people
have talked about, about how to
bring the Internet to the poor.
But they involve a lot of steps.
You have to give them laptops.
You have to keep the laptops
safe from the elements
or from theft.
You have to make sure that
people are literate so
that they can use the Internet.
You have to make sure they're
literate in a language that
exists on the Internet.
You can't really take all
of those things for granted.
But Rose realized, with a
simple push of a button,
if you could wire it up so that
people could talk to someone
who spoke their language on the
other end of the line, that's
how they could get access
to the full power of what
the Internet could offer.
So she launched an
initiative called
Question Box, which
today is operating
in many cities in
India and Africa.
That was a lightning
bolt in some ways.
In a moment, looking around,
paying attention, she saw it.
But you hardly ever start
with a lightning bolt.
You start by caring.
You start by looking at
your own experiences,
the way that you see
the world uniquely.
If Rose hadn't
been to Nicaragua,
if she hadn't taken
that family trip,
she probably never would
have dug deeply enough
to find that solution.
For all of us, we have
things that we've studied,
passions, hobbies, cultural
backgrounds, things
that we've experienced.
Oftentimes that's
the starting point.
So in the course of researching
"Stand Out," I discovered
that there are five
principal areas of finding
your breakthrough idea,
five chief ways that,
with all of these thinkers-- you
don't have to do all of these,
but it's a bit of a
smorgasbord, where people
draw from one or
maybe two, and it
begins to inspire a cascade of
the kind of breakthrough ideas
they get known for.
So I wanted to share with you
some of the stories about them
in hopes that maybe some of
them might be a trigger for you
to go deeper and develop
further some of the ideas
that you are nurturing.
This gentleman is
named Eric Schott.
He's actually someone
I used to consult for.
He's the head of the Genomics
Research Institute at Mount
Sinai Hospital in New York.
What's significant
about Eric, and part
of why I included
him in "Stand Out,"
is that today he's actually
one of the most cited
scientific researchers
in the world.
He's done more than
200 peer reviewed
papers on almost any
disease imaginable.
The reason he's
been so successful
in the world of biology,
interestingly enough,
is that he didn't
start in biology.
His initial training was in
math and computer science.
And, as you guys
might appreciate
more than most, that gave him
a quantitative way of looking
at the world, a
quantitative orientation,
so that when he entered
biology later in his career
and he looked at it, he realized
that the power of big data--
which was just
starting to become
possible thanks to the rapid
progress in genetic sequencing
that was happening in the late
'90s and early 2000s-- people
weren't taking
advantage of that,
because classically
trained biologists
hadn't needed quantitative
skills in that way.
But because Eric had come
from a different world,
he saw the potential
and dove into it.
And it enabled him to make
breakthroughs much faster
than almost anyone else.
One of the key elements
when it comes to innovation
is combining disciplines,
combining perspectives.
It becomes incredibly
hard if you
are too steeped in
one methodology,
whether it is the methodology
of a discipline, or even
just the methodology, the
ideology of one company,
one way of looking at the world.
If all you know is one thing,
it becomes very, very hard
to tell the difference
between doing something one
way, because that is the best
way or the only way that works,
and doing it one way
because it's habit.
If you bring different
perspectives together,
you're able to question and
to see what is mere habit
and what, if the circumstances
have changed in the interim,
might be ripe for disruption
and more productive change.
The second thing that I learned
in talking to these thought
leaders about how to
develop breakthrough ideas
is the importance
of what I will call
tackling a worthy challenge.
Now I do a lot a
podcast interviews.
I've done well over 100
of them since the launch
of "Stand Out," and one of
the questions that they often
ask in the podcast is, "Who are
the entrepreneurs that people
admire?"
And I've listened to
lots of other podcasts,
and so I've heard a
cross-section of answers.
And I'd be curious
what you guys think,
but when other entrepreneurs
and writers are interviewed,
what I hear on these podcasts,
and in write-ups, probably nine
times out of 10, if they are
citing a living person who
is their greatest inspiration,
they always cite Elon Musk.
And the reason I think they do
that is that he is someone who,
probably more unabashedly the
most, is willing to aim big
and to think big.
Solar power, exploring the
heavens, electric cars.
Those are challenges so big
they get people excited.
That's what fuels
Google, in many ways,
all the exciting initiatives
that you guys are
doing with Google X and beyond.
They're projects that
attract the greatest minds.
People want to be
a part of them.
Peter Diamandis, who's a
business author and Silicon
Valley thinker, has
a saying that I like.
"The fastest way to
make a billion dollars
is to help a billion people."
There's a power in a big idea,
because it becomes easier
to get other people
on board with you,
to get other people excited, to
give you funding, to help you,
to join with you.
You get the talent you need,
and that creates momentum.
This woman here is named
Rita Gunther McGrath.
She's a professor at Columbia.
And a couple of
years ago she wrote
a book called "The End of
Competitive Advantage."
And the book has been lauded.
Rita, in fact, has been named
one of the top 10 management
thinkers in the world.
And part of the reason for
that, and part of the reason
I talk to her about this,
is that in her book,
she took on one of
the most cherished
ideas in management
thinking, the idea
of competitive advantage
Michael Porter, and
others, for a long time--
for decades-- the
wisdom in business
was that you needed,
as a business,
to find a competitive advantage
and then keep it at all costs.
What is your sustainable
competitive advantage?
Rita McGrath was one
of the first thinkers
to begin to probe that idea in
light of the changes, massively
disruptive changes that
we've been experiencing
in our economy.
The fact that in the
pace is picking up.
It's been picking up so
fast that even regular,
everyday customers
are seeing it.
People who carried a BlackBerry
five years ago almost
certainly don't have
a BlackBerry today.
People who shopped at
Circuit City, people
who shopped at Borders are
not shopping there today.
We see it with our own eyes.
And Rita was one
of the first people
to write a detailed
book about what
to do in that new environment.
When sustainable competitive
advantage is gone,
how do you bake innovation
into everything that you do?
What's the next step?
That's a question that
people care about.
If you can ride the
wave, if you can
find an idea that people
are already interested in--
that people are already talking
about and want an answer t--
and begin to make a move towards
solving it, the power of that
will bring people along with
you and help your idea gain
traction.
Now another strategy,
a third strategy
that I discovered in the course
of talking to these experts,
is the niche strategy.
This gentleman here
is named Sophal Ear.
Today he's a professor
at Occidental College
in Los Angeles, but he
didn't start out there.
When he was a baby, his mother
rescued him and his four
siblings, and they
escaped together
from the Khmer
Rouge in Cambodia.
She was able, amazingly, in
the midst of all the killing
and genocide going on, to
get her entire family out.
And first they were
refugees in France,
and then eventually they
made it to the United States.
Sophal grew up and
did well in school,
pursued an academic
career, and decided
to become a political scientist.
But in academia, as you guys
know, the foundation of Google
is page rank, and where
does page rank come from?
Well, it was inspired
by academic citations.
The more citations you have,
the better off you are.
And if you are an aspiring young
academic, where the incentives
are is, you want to write
about a topic that is sexy,
that everyone is talking about,
so that everyone will cite you.
That's the sheer mathematics
of getting jobs in academia.
So if you're a political
economist, what do you study?
China, maybe, India, Brazil,
some of these burgeoning,
growing economies.
But Sophal wanted to
do something different.
He wanted to understand
his homeland.
That is why he was
doing what he was doing.
He wanted to
understand it and he
wanted to find ways to
give back because, he says,
I was lucky to get
out of Cambodia alive.
So he became a
Cambodian specialist.
It might seem like the kiss
of death for a young academic.
Cambodia's an interesting place,
but it's certainly not yet
a superpower.
But what Sophal's
example shows, and part
of why I wanted to include
him in "Stand Out,"
is that sometimes,
counterintuitively,
the narrower you go at first,
if you keep the orientation
that the first door you enter
isn't the last door-- it's just
a hallway, and there are
doors off of it-- if that's
how you begin thinking about
your professional life,
you can go in a lot of
surprising and powerful
directions.
Sophal wrote his dissertation
about foreign aid in Cambodia,
and so he developed an expertise
in foreign aid generally.
That was great, but
perhaps more surprising
is the fact that one of
the things that he ended up
studying in the course
of studying Cambodia
was livestock.
He had to write a paper
because his adviser was
advising an agricultural
commission for the UN.
It might seem pretty random,
but when the bird flu epidemic
struck, it turned
out that Sophal
was one of the few experts
operating in America
who actually had deep
familiarity with southeast
Asian livestock practices.
And he became a noted
expert on avian flu.
In fact, starting
again with Cambodia,
Sophal was able to give a
very popular Ted talk-- which,
if you guys haven't seen
it, I recommend it--
about criminal justice.
And his entry point was
the Khmer Rouge tribunals.
You start with Cambodia, but
you end up with the world.
If you can establish
an expertise
in a narrow enough
area-- there's
a phenomenon in psychology
known as the halo effect,
and essentially what
it says is that if you
come to be recognized as
having expertise for one thing,
you will be viewed,
in general, by people
as talented and smart and good.
This is why we
get the phenomenon
of actors who get
to be politicians,
or business leaders who get
to move into other fields.
It's because people generalize.
And so if you are able to
own a niche and go deep,
that gives you a powerful
base, a powerful toehold
to expand out and develop
your brand as someone
who's really knowledgeable.
Another area-- which I
think often gets overlooked,
but I think, particularly
in a place like Google,
can be really powerful-- is
research, doing research.
When I talk to people
sometimes, when
I'm advising businesses and
professionals about this,
they say, oh, that's great.
Sure, of course
research can be helpful.
But I don't have time
to do a doctorate,
or I don't have the money
to do a national survey.
Of course.
I mean, those things are great.
But research, even
on small levels,
can be incredibly useful
and powerful as a tool.
It could be case studies.
It could be reviews.
It could be white papers.
It could be somehow just
going deep to provide
some kind of quantitative new
information, or qualitative,
for that matter.
And my favorite example of
this is this gentleman here.
His name is Michael Waxenberg.
And Michael, I discovered,
was an IT manager
for a financial
services company.
That was his job.
It was and is his job.
But completely
inadvertently, he was
able to develop a really
lucrative and enjoyable
sideline for himself.
It all started
about 15 years ago.
He was living in New York
City with his family,
and he had just gotten
the announcement
that his condo, the apartment
that he was living in,
was going to be condo-ized.
And he had to make a decision
about whether his family would
buy their unit.
So Michael, he was
a data-driven guy.
He wanted to make a good
decision about this.
So he started going to open
houses and visiting them.
That's not very different
than what you or I might do.
But what he did do that
was very different was,
he started writing
reviews of the properties
that he visited, not quick,
one-line, "This place is great,
this place sucks."
Really detailed reviews.
It started out more
for his own benefit
than anything, just so he
could keep them straight.
But instead of keeping that
information to himself,
he posted it publicly
on a real estate
website called Street Easy.
And as a result, as he
posted more and more, he
started getting emails off the
website with people saying,
I love your reviews.
They're fantastic.
Will you represent me?"
And he had to write back and
say, well, thank you so much,
but I'm not a realtor.
And so he started
advising people just
for fun on the side, but they
couldn't give him any money.
He wasn't licensed.
They'd give him boxes of
chocolates or bottles of wine.
But he couldn't really
do anything with it.
But more and more people
started coming to him.
And eventually a realtor
approached him and said, look,
you already have a client base.
If you haven't done
this yet, I will sponsor
you to become a realtor.
And so Michael got his
license, and now, for years,
has been operating, with
no marketing whatsoever,
a side business as a real
estate agent selling houses
here and there and
having people come to him
on the strength of his reviews.
Now for me, what's critical
here, this didn't cost money.
It took a little time.
But it's nothing that
any of us can't do.
Sometimes people think
research, and they
think it has to
be technical, they
think it has to be complicated.
But whether it's a review
of real estate, whether it's
writing up and in-depth
report about something,
we live in a world now, the
Internet world, where everyone
has an opinion, where, in
fact, half of what you look at
is someone's opinion
about someone's opinion
about the Kardashians.
What we need more of is facts.
What we need more
of is people who
are doing what Michael did
with thoughtful research,
thoughtful, primary
source research.
That's something that with
a little time and effort,
any of us can do.
Finally, the fifth
strategy that I discovered
in the course of
writing "Stand Out"
was what I call
creating a framework.
Some of you guys
may know this guy.
He has a lot of devotees.
His name is David
Allen, and he is
the powerhouse behind Getting
Things Done, the productivity
system.
Now part of what I would argue
makes David Allen and Getting
Things Done so popular, so
powerful, is the fact that just
about everybody these days has
some kind of productivity tip
about, oh, do this with your
inbox, or do that with your
To Do list.
David Allen has a system.
He has a thorough system
that helps you understand
and explain not just,
here's what to do now,
but to put productivity
into context.
We often think, oh, people have
been doing this for decades.
People have been doing
this for hundreds of years.
Everything that should have
been said has been said.
But not really.
It wasn't until 30 years
ago that Robert Cialdini
developed the six principles
of influence and persuasion.
People have been
studying persuasion
from the beginning of time.
I mean, you look back
hundreds of years,
you see Machiavellis'
"The Prince."
People care about what
it takes to persuade
someone of something.
But Robert Cialdini, a
great, eminent researcher
from Arizona State University,
was able to be the first person
to say, you know what?
When it comes to
influence and persuasion,
there's actually only
six ways to do it.
Here's what they are.
And it turned out
that was so helpful,
that was so instructive, almost
any time now that influence
and persuasion is
mentioned, Robert Cialdini
is mentioned along with it.
Now, with David Allen,
any time somebody
says, oh, I'm so stressed out,
I have way too many emails
to respond to, people
say, have you thought
about Getting Things Done?
If you can create an
explanatory framework--
whether it's Maslow's
hierarchy of needs
or Elizabeth Kubler-Ross's
five stages of grief,
anything like that--
those are famous examples,
but even on the
microscopic level,
if you can create structures
that help people understand
a task better, a job
better, a field better,
that can be enormously powerful.
In fact, going a
little meta, that's
what I'm trying to
do with "Stand Out,"
is to try to help explain
the strategies of how
to become a recognized
expert in your field.
But of course, coming
up with the idea
is only half the battle.
It's only the first step.
And so I wanted to
just touch briefly
on this question
of how do you build
a following around your idea?
How do you get it known?
How do you get it
recognized by other people?
I'll argue, based on
the research that I
did interviewing these
top thought leaders,
that it is a three-step
process to share
your idea with the
world and really
begin to have it gain momentum
and be fully recognized.
The first step is building
your network, the second step,
building your audience, the
third, building your community.
I'll tackle them in turn.
This woman is Kari Anderson.
And I profiled
her in "Stand Out"
as kind of the exemplar
of building your network,
because she had-- I've known
her for a number of years,
but it actually
wasn't until I started
talking to her for this
book that I discovered
the story that she had that
I thought was so remarkable,
I knew I had to share it.
Kari, it turns out,
used to be a journalist.
And in 1989 she created a
kind of mastermind group
of fellow journalists, where
they would get together
monthly, trade ideas about
stories, about the profession,
about how to do
their jobs better.
And it was so powerful for her,
it was such a good experience,
such a good learning experience,
that a few years later,
when she had shifted over to
become a professional speaker,
she started a second
mastermind group, in 1994,
of fellow speakers to do the
same thing, just half a dozen
or so people meeting once
a month to trade ideas.
Now a lot of people do
with something like that.
But what I thought
was amazing was
that it turns out Kari is still
meeting with these groups.
20 and 25 years later,
she's meeting monthly
with the same people.
And she says that
this has actually
been one of the most singular
professional experiences
of her life.
Now the moral of
the story is not
that we all need to start
mastermind groups that
last a quarter
century, although I'm
sure it would be beneficial.
But what I take
from her experience
is that the most
important thing, the most
important step-- and I
heard this again and again
from the thought leaders
that I profiled-- you have
to start with a base of people.
You have to start with a small
base of trusted colleagues
that you respect and listen
to and have honest connections
with, so that they
aren't afraid to tell you
when your idea is
amazing, and they
aren't afraid to tell you
when your idea is bad,
so that you can refine it.
And by the time you
share it with the world,
by the time you begin
building a broader audience,
it's in as good a shape
is it can possibly be.
Too few of us have this,
because we're responding
to stimuli all day long.
Maybe we need to listen to
David Allen a little bit more,
because for a lot of us,
the people we hang out with,
the people we spend time with,
it's the people who email us.
Who do you have coffee with?
Who do you have lunch with?
Well, guess what?
For a lot of us,
it's whoever asks.
That's not how it should be.
We need to be more
deliberate about thinking
through, who are the
three people, the five
people, the eight people that
we most want to be spending time
with, the people that we want
to learn from, the people
we truly respect and
who raise our game?
If we can be proactive about
spending time with them,
that is one of the most
important career moves
that we can make,
because they can
provide us with the insights
and support that we need.
That's the first step.
The second step, of course--
because if an idea is going
to spread, it can't
just be with people
you know-- the second step
is building your audience.
And fortunately these days,
we have more ability than ever
to do something like that.
We are able to blog about
it, to give speeches
like this about it.
We can Tweet, we
can go on Pinterest,
we can share it on social
media, we can do webinars,
we can have podcasts.
There's a million
ways of spreading it.
But still we have
a lot of people
who are shy about
standing out, people
who are nervous about
sharing their ideas for fear
that they might be shot down.
But first of all, if you have
this trusted group of advisers
who have given
you feedback, then
by the time your idea reaches
the place where you're
able to begin sharing
it with the world,
you've already had some
smart eyes looking at it.
There's already a
pretty good chance
that your idea has
some merit to it.
But really the way that
I think about this--
and I take the image
from a conversation I
had with a thinker named John
Hegel from Deloitte Center
for the Edge.
He said that putting
your ideas out there,
whether it's blogging or
using some other method,
it's like putting a light out.
It's like sharing a
beacon and putting it out
there so that like minded people
can see it and come to you.
In this noisy,
crowded world, we have
to make ourselves discoverable.
There are-- with seven
billion people in the world,
there are people who care about
the things that you care about.
There are people who see the
world the same way that you do.
There are people
who need your ideas.
But it's loud.
There's a lot of
material out there.
They have to be
able to find you,
and they can't do
it unless we're
willing to step up
and share our ideas.
And it could be something
as simple as putting out
a blog post on LinkedIn in
or starting a Twitter account
where you don't even have to
put out your own ideas at first.
It can just be
curating what you think
is interesting around
subjects you care about.
But it's beginning to find
a way to put the pings out
into the universe, to see
if you get an echo back.
Now we're all busy.
And one of the challenges-- I
hear this talking to people all
the time-- is, OK,
Dorie, that's great,
but how do I have time
to create content, or be
active on social media,
or any of these things
when I have a crazy
job and I'm busy
and I'm being stretched
too thin anyway?
And I respect that.
I think that it's true for
most of us, if not all of us.
I think the key
here, and something
that I want to
highlight, something
that I talk about in "Stand
Out," is the power of leverage.
Some of you may
recognize this guy.
He's fairly well
known in the tech
space, Robert Scoble, well-known
opinion leader in technology.
And when I interviewed
Robert for this book,
he told me something
interesting.
He's somebody who gets hundreds,
if not thousands, of emails
a day.
He's constantly being
contacted by startups
that would like to talk
to him or get his advice
or have him feature
them in some forum.
And what he says,
what he told me,
is that when someone
asks him a question,
when they email him a question,
he writes back and he says,
I would be happy to answer your
question, but not on email.
What he tells them
instead is that they
should post their question on
Quora, the question and answer
website, and that he
will answer it there.
And the reason he
says he does it
is that, he says, if I
email someone the answer,
I've helped one person.
But if I put the
answer on the Internet,
I'm able to help five people
or 50 people or 500 people.
That's how we need
to start thinking.
All of us have
too many meetings.
All of us suffer
from too little time.
If we can begin to
think strategically
about how we can leverage our
impact, leverage our ideas,
share them with more people
with the same amount of effort,
that's what it's going to take
to enable our ideas to really
grow and spread.
Finally, what I discovered
in the course of researching
"Stand Out," is that when
you start with building
your network, you
start small, you
start with this
close-knit, trusted group,
you move to building your
audience, going one to many,
talking to a larger group.
Those are all important steps.
But when an idea
fully takes shape,
when it begins to
grow to a level
where things are
happening on its own,
where the dominoes
are falling, what
happens in that moment is
that your audience, which
has been listening to you,
starts talking to each other.
And that is the moment where an
audience becomes a community.
So one example,
perhaps, near and dear
to some of your tech
hearts, "The Lean Startup."
This is Eric Ries, the
author of that book,
bestseller a couple
of years ago.
Today there are more than
750,000 people worldwide
who are registered for
Lean Startup meetup groups.
That's more people,
certainly, than Eric Ries
could address in a room,
maybe even in a year,
maybe even in a lifetime.
It's a huge number of
people who are voluntarily
organizing around that idea.
And what I discovered
in the course of writing
and researching "Stand
Out," is that if you
want your idea to go viral,
if you want your audience
members to start talking
to each other about them
and forming a community
around your idea,
two things need to happen.
There's a technical element.
You want to try to find a way
to make it easy for people
to talk to each other.
Maybe it's by having a
conference like The Lean
Startup does every year.
Maybe it's by having meetup
groups where people can
get together around the world.
Eric Ries will
sometimes call in.
He'll do Skype calls with new
chapters to encourage them.
Maybe it's creating an
online message board,
or a Google Groups, or some
form of online discussion,
of Facebook page,
whatever it is,
but some way that people can
be in touch with each other
directly and have those
conversations without you,
because an idea will always
spread farther if you're not
the only one saying it.
But that's the
technical element.
Even more than the technical
is the philosophical.
If your idea is really going
to spread, from the beginning,
something important needs
to be baked into your idea.
And that is, it
has to have value
for people other than yourself.
The reason that people
are going to spread ideas
is that they feel that it's
relevant to their own lives.
They see themselves in it.
They feel that it's helpful.
For Eric Ries, it's not about
supporting him or making
his book a bestseller.
That's nice, but what
people care about
is making it less likely that
their startup is going to fail.
They're having
these conversations
because they want to
be more successful,
and they view that as a tool.
If your idea has utility
for other people,
if other people can see in it a
way to better their own lives,
they want to share that
message, and they're
going to be excited to do so.
And that is how you
can build a movement.
In today's society,
moving faster than ever,
it is increasingly
critical to stand out.
In fact, standing out
is no longer optional.
We need to find ways
to make an impact.
In an Internet-driven society,
there's a race to the bottom.
People are being commoditized.
They're looking for the
lowest price option.
And we need to give employers
and customers a reason
to choose us specifically.
We have to find a
way to stand out.
It doesn't mean that
every single person
has to be a world
expert in something.
But it does mean that,
whether it's in our company,
or in our department,
or in our community,
it's increasingly
essential for us
to ask, what can I do
that no one else can do?
What can I do better
than anyone else?
How can I bring my
unique experiences
to bear on this problem
or on this challenge?
We used to live in a world
where what mattered most
was how you were similar
to everybody else.
Did you think the same way?
Did you toe the company line?
What matters most today is
the differences you bring
and the fact that you do
see the world differently
than everyone else.
That's the power
of standing out.
Thank you very much.
Anyway, now that I know
that there actually
is time for questions,
I would love
to take any of your comments,
if you would like to have them.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You talked about how
having a broad experience
can help you come up with
new and interesting ideas.
But you also talked about
finding a niche and diving
deep.
How do you sort of
balance those two aspects?
DORIE CLARK: Fantastic question.
How do you balance
the distinction
between going broad and drawing
from all kinds of experiences,
and also niching down.
So number one, you don't
necessarily have to do both.
You could choose
either approach,
and either one could
be a winning approach.
But let's say you
wanted to do them both.
So I'm going to
make up an example.
Let's say you work at Google,
and you have a special passion.
All your life you have been a
really serious jazz musician,
and that's something that's
pretty distinct from everyone
else here, let's pretend.
So if that's the
case, that would
be drawing in those things,
what can you do to niche down?
Let's say you decide-- I
mean, I know within Google,
one of the great
things that I've
heard from the many friends that
I have working in the company,
is that there's a
lot of opportunity
for people to move
around into different job
roles, different offices
in a lot of ways.
After rotations,
in certain areas,
you can sort of raise
your hand and say hey,
I'm interested in
moving over here.
Maybe, because of
this background,
you have decided that there's a
particular niche that you might
be able to dive
deep on, that you
have a special relationship to.
Let's say wearable
technology for musicians,
and how that could improve the
sonic experience if they're
wearing some whatever whatever.
And I don't know enough about
either technology or music
to be able to get more
specific than that.
But it's by bringing together
the different elements
of what excites you
and what's different,
where, because you're doing
this digging and exploration,
you can start to see, in the
process of looking into it,
where there might be elements
that could be helpful.
You could do the same thing with
running or sports or whatever.
But there's places
that you can go deep,
and because you have
ties to that community
and a special understanding
as a practitioner,
you have immediately
more credibility,
and probably more
knowledge starting
in on it, that can give you an
advantage when you niche down.
Did that answer your question?
Great.
Thank you.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So how do you avoid
the selection bias that
comes with just looking at
people who succeeded, and then
maybe something that
most of them did
is actually a thing
that most of the time
doesn't work well for
the people that do it,
but you're not looking at the
people who didn't succeed,
so you don't know-- how
do you avoid that issue?
DORIE CLARK: Fantastic question.
You don't, is my answer.
One of my goals is, I
actually started my career
as a journalist, and so
my ambition from the start
was to go deep and to tell
interesting qualitative
stories about the people who
are the most successful today.
I agree with you entirely that a
cross-sectional study of people
who have succeeded,
people who have failed,
you know, the sort of
big picture, big data,
even-- maybe we can
get Eric Schott on it--
look at success and failure
today in a variety of fields
would be a really interesting
and worthy problem to tackle.
It was not the problem
that I tackled, however.
For me, I was really interested
in going deep and having
a more qualitative view of some
of the people that I think,
personally, are
pretty interesting.
If any of you guys follow
business literature,
I spoke with Dan
Pink, with Tom Peters,
with Robert Cialdini
with David Allen,
as I mentioned, with Seth Godin.
So they were pretty cool folks.
And then in other fields, I
also drew from them as well.
But great point.
Absolutely.
I was mostly trying to
tell a different story.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for your talk.
And a lot of the factors
that you point out I
can sort of see in play when I
look at some successful people.
But I'm interested
in some factors that
also seem to often pop up
that you didn't mention,
and curious where
you fit them in,
things that I often see pop up.
The role of luck.
You mentioned with a
couple of your people
that oh, all of a
sudden, out of the blue,
there was the avian flu, and
then bang, he was a superstar.
So there's the role of luck.
There's the role of not
just your social network,
but having the right people
in your social network,
the powerful people,
the ones who actually
make the key decisions.
And finally, there
is this dynamic
that everybody else is
trying to stand out, too,
and so you're sort of in a sea
of competition of everybody
trying to stand out, which
you sort of alluded to.
But beyond the general
advice, how do you
pop out to the top of that?
So a lot of factors at play.
What do you think?
DORIE CLARK: Fantastic.
I love it.
So interestingly
enough, I actually
have nearly a whole chapter on
the role of luck in the book.
So I hope you've been
able to grab a copy.
But I'll tell you guys
briefly, luck is actually
one of the more interesting
elements of this,
and one that oftentimes I
actually close the talk with.
So here in Cambridge,
actually, very close to here,
there's a venture capital
firm called Cue Ball Partners.
It's run by a guy named Anthony
Chan and some of his partners.
A few years ago they wrote a
book called "Heart, Smarts,
Guts, and Luck."
It came out, actually, from
Harvard Business Review
Press, which published my
first book, "Reinventing You."
And interestingly
enough, so they
did a pretty wide-ranging
study of entrepreneurs
who'd been successful.
And they broke people down
into four personality types,
actually.
And you can even go
to their website.
They have something called
the EAT, the Entrepreneurial
Assessment Test, which
is kind of fun to take.
And it shows you what your
dominant personality type is.
The first three, to me, make
fairly intuitive sense, right?
Hearts driven, smarts
driven, guts driven.
We can all imagine
scenarios where
people are able to succeed
because of those qualities.
The one that was a little
bit more mystifying
was luck driven.
What does it even mean?
But it turns out if you peel
it back, interestingly enough,
the research begins to
show, of course luck
is something we can only
attribute post facto, right?
You don't know in the moment
that something is lucky.
It's kind of like, oh,
after it plays out,
then it becomes lucky.
What does it look like
in the moment, however?
It turns out that
lucky entrepreneurs,
or top executives, are
people who actually
have a different personality
type than the other types
of successful professionals.
They are typically
more laid back,
and they exhibit, in large
quantities, two really
important attributes
that all of us
can develop more
of in our lives.
One is curiosity, and
the other is humility.
And the reason that this plays
in is, so many of the people,
so many of the
successful professionals
that they profiled,
they have a mission.
Part of what makes
them successful
is they're so focused, they say,
I'm going to go to this meeting
and I'm going to meet the
head of marketing for Ford.
Or I'm going to go
to this meeting,
and I'm going to meet
venture capitalists
who will give me my Series A
funding, or whatever it is.
But they have this
idea in their head,
and if they don't see
things that loo like that,
they will barrel through,
whereas a lucky entrepreneur
or executive is
someone who is far more
willing to just sit back and
say, oh, this person seems
interesting.
I'll talk to them.
And they wait, and they
see how it plays out,
and they have the conversation.
And they are curious
enough to want
to learn about that person,
and they are humble enough
to realize that
they have something
to learn from that person.
And years later, that is what
plays out and turns to luck.
So I think that that's
one of the coolest things
that I learned from that
book and from that research.
Also, Richard Wiseman
is a psychologist
who's done a lot of
research into luck.
One suggestion
that he has, which
you guys can apply
if you're interested,
there's a factor that comes into
play with almost all humans,
which is that we
really tend to be drawn
to people who are like us.
This is natural.
It's not necessarily good
in terms of diversity
or innovation or whatever.
And so Richard Wiseman
actually talked about somebody
that he interviewed.
And this guy, the way
that he broke out of that
is that he made a
rule for himself,
if he was going to a networking
event or a cocktail party,
that he would pick
a color in advance,
and he would only talk to people
wearing that color so that he
would be forced to choose
different people than he might
normally to talk to.
And that's a way to
increase our luck.
So I think it's a
really rich topic.
Let's talk more afterwards
about your other points,
but I love them.
Really good questions.
Ma'am, what was your
question or comment?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for this talk.
It's really great information.
So I'm just following
up on something you just
said about being
flexible and open,
which is kind of the natural
way that I approach things.
But when you first said
earlier about being deliberate,
I said, uh, that's what
I need to introduce.
So how do you reconcile being
flexible and seeing what's
out there, and allowing yourself
to see the possibilities
with being deliberate
and actually moving
in the direction
that you want to go?
DORIE CLARK: Yeah.
So it's an important question.
And in many ways, it's similar
to the going wide versus going
narrow.
I would say in
general, we can play
choose to play to our strengths,
whatever our strength is.
However, there is a way
to bring them together.
I mean, certainly in terms of
a lot of the career research
that I do, one piece
of advice that I
would give to the
professionals that I
counsel and work with in
my consulting business,
is, have a plan.
But treat it as a hypothesis.
It's something that
you're moving toward so
that you are moving
towards something,
so that you have some
degree of forward momentum.
But don't allow
it to lock you in.
If you see something over
to the side that is better,
or is more interesting, or is
something that you literally
just could not have predicted
because you couldn't have even
seen it until you reached the
halfway point in your march
toward that new thing, then
feel free to veer off and go
do that.
But always have something
that at least provisionally
you're working
toward, so that you're
able to enjoy the benefits
of forward momentum
and seeing things
from new vistas
that you previously
wouldn't have been able to.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DORIE CLARK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is about doing, promoting
an idea on your own like
through a startup versus taking
advantage of the momentum of
being at a place like Google.
So, say if you think
about, like, I don't know,
self-driving cars.
The reason why Google can make
such awesome self-driving cars,
as compared to, say, the
ones that you see prototyped
in academia, is because
Google just has more data,
and they have more people,
and they have more resources,
and they have more
of everything, right?
And infrastructure.
And so if have
this awesome idea,
did you see anything about
whether it makes more
sense for me to try to build
up a startup on my own,
and own the idea to
give it credibility
so that then I can make it into
something huge, or sell it?
Or is it more practical
to try to pitch it
to a company earlier?
But then how do you
build credibility
around the idea instead of
having somebody just toss it
on the back burner?
So I guess going on
your own versus working
with a big company.
DORIE CLARK: Yeah.
Really important.
So there's actually a
couple of questions at play.
One is the personal
branding question.
How do you get known
and get credibility
as being the driving force
behind a certain idea?
And then the other
is the question of,
where is the best home
for that idea in terms
of operationalizing
it, and actually making
sure that it has the resources
necessary to be successful.
In the Silicon Valley ecosystem,
acqui-hires are a big thing
now, where companies,
as you guys well know,
large companies will
snap up a smaller company
because they want the
development talent.
And they will shutter the
projects with impunity,
and say, OK, fellas, now
you're working on this.
And that's a real thing.
So I think that in a
technical sense, about what
is necessary for the
success of an idea,
I think that it's important
to keep in mind a few things.
Number one, is it feasible
to do the idea on your own?
Sometimes, literally,
it's not, because you
need to have data or
access to other resources
that only a big
company could provide.
If you realize that in
three months, or six months,
or a year, you were going to be
hitting a wall that you can't
surmount because you literally
don't have access to the tools
you need, then it probably
does fundamentally
need to be done within the
confines of a larger system.
If you do decide to
partner with a company,
then it's a question
of making sure
that you have contracts
and legal protections,
as much as you possibly can,
that validate this idea is not
going to be shuttered,
and that you have ways
of protecting it and keeping
it as an ongoing concern,
perhaps with a sort
of special mandate.
When it comes to
your personal brand,
one of the things
that I'll advise--
and I'll just wrap up because
we're getting the curtain
warning here momentarily-- but
one of the things that I think
is important for all
of us to be aware of
is the amazing resource
that is content creation.
Sometimes people come to me
and they say, well, you know,
I have these great ideas.
But I don't want to talk
about them because someone
might steal them.
And you hear this
a lot from people.
And so my asterisk
on this, OK, sure.
If you have this amazing,
patentable engineering
innovation, great.
Go patent it, go do that,
go protect that first.
But if you have
an idea, and it's
an idea about the nature
of leadership or something
like that, you can't patent it.
But it doesn't go anywhere
if you don't talk about it.
Is there going to be a risk
that someone might steal it?
Maybe.
But I will tell you the very
best insurance against it
is for you to be everywhere
talking about it, because if I
came to you and
said, hey, I have
a really great idea for a book
about women's empowerment.
It's called "Lean In," you
would laugh in my face,
and you'd say, I
think that's been
done by Sheryl Sandberg, Dorie,
and it doesn't go any further.
Everyone knows that's her idea.
And so the antidote to
anyone stealing your ideas,
or your idea dying, for that
matter, is to get the word out.
And so I would say if you want
to be known and associated
for something, go
nuts with blogging,
with content creation,
being out there,
touting it, so that your name
is almost inextricably entwined
with it.
And then that way, whether
you get acquired, partner
with somebody, or not, you're
going to be known as the go
to person behind that idea.
So thank you so much
for your question.
Thank you, everybody,
for having me.
And have a great day.